[Music]
we as a species are living longer
right now the average american lives for
about 80 years and the question is
how long could we live
we actually don't know the answer to
that
this question is at the center of the
burgeoning field of longevity science
and biotech startups believe we are
closer than ever to unprecedented
lifespan
a recent explosion of longevity startups
has created a new speculative industry
almost overnight
oxford economics estimated longevity to
be worth 7.6 trillion dollars
in order to
reach its potential right really needs
to have a way of getting to the market
as fast as we can possibly do it but
some fear whatever breakthrough may
happen will never really serve the
average person
rather it will favor the few who are
sinking their fortunes into these
startups
it's a pretty concentrated group of
investors from our estimates it's like
nearly 50 percent has come from
individuals
that's a nicer way of saying
billionaires
i have to be honest a large part is
egoistic because the billionaires they
are getting older and they have a lot of
money and they still have a lot of
ambitions they want to live longer when
they age better when people think about
longevity
the thing that comes to mind is usually
you know some eccentric billionaire
trying to live forever but what
longevity really is is just the science
of helping us live longer and also the
science of helping us live more
healthfully
anything that comes out of this space
won't be just for the rich
humans have been trying to cheat death
since we climbed down from the trees
the fountain of youth was a mythical
place where you could drink waters from
its springs to rejuvenate your aging
body it first appeared in writing around
the 5th century bc and the search hasn't
stopped since
folklore has it that spanish explorer
ponce de leon searched in vain for
magical waters with restorative powers
in modern day florida and the bahamas
but historians agree that most of his
time was actually spent searching for
something a bit more
earthly not only was he searching for
gold but expeditions like his were
expensive and in constant need of
fundraising from the throne across the
atlantic
[Music]
today the modern quest for prolonged
youth remains very expensive
last year more than two billion dollars
in venture funding
went into the longevity space so this is
a space that people are excited about
and they are putting their money into it
but this expedition is funded mostly by
a different sort of royalty
we have heard recently you know
that famous people such as jeff bezos
invested um not not only millions but
actually billions into new startup
companies
and i think you know it is totally
justified this investment
while this narrative of the super rich
making an elixir of life for themselves
at the expense of the rest of the world
makes for good bond villain material it
doesn't hold up to close scrutiny i love
this the narrative about
lots of billionaires coming into this
longevity space it's played up more than
it needs to be because in general like
vc funds
are backed by billionaires or families
of billionaires this is sort of the
the artery of
the the worldwide innovation economy is
people who have the capital on hand to
be able to do these big sometimes risky
investments i don't think that
impression is entirely wrong but it's
also not fully correct and it really
fails to recognize the ways in which
the edges of human knowledge and
capacity are always explored on the
outskirts by
a handful of individuals who are
uniquely motivated and uniquely
resourced
it never happens with technology that
somehow that that then stays secretive
and closed up in a box and only
effective for them
as it turns out the science of
pharmacology and even the basic laws of
supply and demand don't really allow for
an elite super drug
that first pill that you create or that
first injection or whatever it is that
might cost
you know 500 million dollars to make
that first pill the second one probably
costs a fraction of a penny
and so if you were to do the math of
like the supply and demand aspects of
this it doesn't make sense to make a
really expensive
medicine that only a few billionaires
take when you can make something really
cheap but make it for everybody
and there's another reason why private
billionaires and vcs are flooding this
space
as it turns out longevity health doesn't
exactly fit into the current health care
model making it risky and more
complicated to traditional
pharmaceutical investors the major
regulatory bodies that look at states of
disease so the cdc the fda they don't
consider death and illness
of all of the
clinical end points that we generally
look at
therapeutics alleviating the suffering
of humans
interestingly death isn't one of them
many people very accurately particularly
as we live longer and healthier lives
are pausing and saying
well wait why do i wait to get involved
with the healthcare system until i'm
sick and why is there no baseline of
what being healthy is there have been a
lot of people with resources i.e
billionaires who are saying i know the
best practices for living long and
healthy lives but what are the
treatments to alleviate some of these
symptoms of aging
and all the classic investors in the
space said
i don't really know how to fathom that i
don't know what to do with these kind of
soft clinical endpoints and i absolutely
don't know how to invest on a metric of
you make an investment today you engage
with a therapeutic practice and then
hopefully we find out in 50 years that
you lived 10 healthier years than you
might have otherwise right that that
feedback loop is way too long
and that's really what's enabled
investors like ourselves to
start participating in this market
what's more longevity science itself
challenges much of the healthcare status
quo as we know it
everyone in the space agrees that for
real longevity to be achieved there
needs to be a massive paradigm shift
we are locked into a system where we
wait for people to get sick
and then try to treat them and that
system worked really well a hundred
years ago when infectious diseases were
the cause of death for everybody if you
come in with a heart attack or with
stage three cancer or with early stage
alzheimer's disease
so much has already broken down in our
bodies by the time that that doctor has
seen that patient that it is so complex
to imagine how we would fix all of the
pieces that have come apart all of these
future technologies these future
medicines they're built around this idea
of prevention the notion that we could
switch from a healthcare system that is
primarily reactive wait for someone to
get sick to one that is more proactive
right give someone a drug so that they
could then stay healthy so a more
technically accurate term for a
longevity drug would be a multi-disease
preventative something that can keep you
from getting cancer or alzheimer's
disease or having a heart attack the
amazing potential of this science is
that
we could have a single drug that
makes all of those things happen further
in the future than they would otherwise
have
as of today a single longevity drug
remains as real as the fountain of youth
and experts agree that regardless of the
technology longevity is a multi-pronged
effort using everything from biomarkers
and cellular rejuvenation to gene
editing diet and exercise there will
likely never be a one-size-fits-all
solution
and to accomplish this longevity
startups are taking an interdisciplinary
approach to the science
scientists have really started breaking
down
all of the little things that happen to
us as we age and there are a lot of them
but i like to break them down into three
categories our top category is stuff
that happens at the whole tissue level
we call it like changes in how our
tissues are put together we have stem
cells that get exhausted as we age and
now they can't make new copies of
themselves and then if you zoom in into
the cell there are changes that happened
at the molecular level specific
molecules that can't be broken down by
our normal recycling mechanisms that
build up little by little as we get
older
the business model of these startups
largely mirror this diverse approach
casting a wide net across both academic
science and pharmacology
it's kind of a new model where you don't
focus on one single technology or one
single therapeutic area because
longevity is a very complex approach
where many biological mechanisms are
interacted and intertwined
so we'd like to have the scientists
interacting with each other even though
they have a specific scientific field
[Music]
we have like an incubator space
we bring in
a cutting-edge science
we collaborate with academic leaders in
the field and we bring in scientific
entrepreneurs to bring this breakthrough
science into our labs here in zurich
so we have labs and offices and then we
have very experienced traditional pharma
people who know how to discover and
develop drugs in this completely novel
field
where we find a great scientist who has
made a discovery bring it into cambrian
and then use the fact that we have a
team of chemists and drug developers and
researchers and you know people who
understand the biotech market and all of
this to foster that
internally this aggregation model helps
biotechs hedge their bets against an
admittedly high risk venture
drug development is risky right so when
you start a drug in clinical trials or
human trials you only have about a one
in seven chance of that drug making it
all the way through its three phases of
clinical trials to approval
but if you pull together
20 of these different ideas into
one entity
and
resource them all
then all of a sudden that risk goes up
to about a 95 chance that you'll get at
least one hit and so the math of drug
development makes a lot more sense as a
collective than as individuals
even with so many bets on the table
there's no guarantee that a breakthrough
will happen under their roof recently a
study funded through traditional grants
out of the salk institute successfully
extended the lifespan of mice and while
mouse studies are not considered
breakthrough discoveries it has gotten
the attention of the scientific
community
we developed an approach called partial
reprogramming basically where we express
a set of genes
which can actually reprogram the cells
without losing their identity
we
were able to erase the signs of aging we
were able to extend its life by 30
percent almost so basically this kind of
demonstrate that partial reprogramming
is a way to uh reverse some of the
aging marks in cells and tissues and
which can eventually have a beneficial
effect on the whole organism
the partially proving approach was even
tested in human cells so we were able to
revert take cells from an aged
individual and apply this partial
reprogramming and erase the signs of
aging in the cell so the conceptually it
works even in human cells
the key word here is conceptually
the science is in such early stages and
it grows every day what we have is all
of these really interesting
data points right from human studies
from mouse studies but we're many many
years if not decades away from concrete
answers that tell us how these things
contribute to how we age
and this speaks to another misconception
about longevity this community as a
whole isn't so much focused on
increasing our lifespan as much as they
are on improving our quality of life as
we age
it's not our aim and i don't think
anyone can prevent death right
ultimately we will still all die but our
aim is that until we die that we have
the best life that we can have
in the longevity world
almost nobody's talking about lifespan
they're all talking about health span
the amount of time that we spend in good
health
and if we prioritize extending health
span
increasing lifespan may be a side effect
of that
[Music]
you